Hi, I'm Lacey Carmichael volunteer coordinator at ministries of
Jesus. There are over 150 volunteers that
give more than 16,000 hours annually.
We are excited to get to know you and see
how God is going to use your gifts and abilities to serve
our community.
Intakes are vital part of our ministry Jennifer
the one who trains our
intake volunteers, we'll walk you through how to do an
intake that way. You know what our patients get
to experience.
I want to take some time today to walk you through
an intake as well as just help you learn how it's an
educational tool for our patients at MOJ.
We often refer to the intake as the tool that helps
us keep on our mission. And so all of our
staff have been through the intake our patients go through
it regularly. So we wanted to give an opportunity for our volunteers
to experience what that intake looks like so
that when you hear us talk about it, you know exactly what we're referring to
so you should have received an intake packet
at your volunteer orientation. So go ahead
and get that out and grab something to write with because you're gonna need that too. The
front page is a consent form. It's just
a legal document We're Not Gonna read through that now so you
can just set that one aside. The second page is
the three-part being has three circles on it
and we're gonna spend just a minute here talking about
how we use this page to help people understand what our
mission at ministries of Jesus is. So it
has the three part being the
Soul and Spirit the body is
what relates to the physical world around us.
It's where we use our five senses and then
we get the soul the mind will and
emotions and that's kind of where we base our decision making
on. How do I feel about something and we act
out of that soul and then God gave us this spirit
and that's the part of us that relates to God and we
try to put other things in there but oftentimes it
never works and we will come up lacking every
time that is for when the Holy
Spirit indwells us when we have that relationship with Jesus Christ.
So God created us as this three-part being a
body. So in a spirit, they're very intricately woven.
You cannot separate one part from the other and
that's by Design. So when somebody comes to ministries
of Jesus and they want physical help through
our Medical Clinic, there's often an
underlying emotional issue. They haven't dealt with and so
we want to be able to treat them em,
Only so we can refer them say to our
counseling area and then of course throughout everything
that we do we offer spiritual guidance and
help and do everything based on scripture. So
that's the three-part being that our Approach
at ministries of Jesus to heal the whole person.
On the questions. I want you to know that it's going
to look a little bit different for you doing this intake
via a video on your own than it
does for our patients that come to ministries of Jesus when
they come here. We are doing them
one-on-one with an intake volunteer. And so
we spend an hour of time walking through these
questions. We read the questions to them because number
one we don't know if they can read and secondly, we
want them to be able to create dialogue
with this. So when we read questions out loud, they think
out loud and then they give us much more
information than just a yes. No answer. So we really
are able to put them at ease and learn more about them. And
then we take those notes and it goes in their medical file. So
a lot different that you're going to experience in
our patients and I just want you to know that going into this but
let's go ahead and look at the questions on page
one. It says physical will at the top
and you'll see that scripture box in the top.
Right that I was mentioning earlier. So you can see kind of
where to read those scriptures and I do again encourage you
to read them as we go so that you can see what God has
to say about these areas of our life. Then Under
The Heading like nutrition those questions, you'll see
one line instruction that says
please check all that are true for you generally speaking
throughout the intake that instruction does not
change, but be aware that
when you get to the relational will and you're doing that one on your
own that those instructions are a little bit different and
so you're going to want to pay attention. Otherwise you'll end up with the wrong
score on your wheels.
then for the questions
On this section. There are five questions. I drink
at least three eight ounce glasses of water a day is the first
one so generally that is not going to be true for anybody
every day. But we want you to answer the questions.
If it's true for you most of the time within the
last two to three months then check the question and then
also be honest if you try to manipulate your
answers so that your wheels turn out really good that defeats
the whole point of the intake. So
be honest with yourself. Nobody else is going to see your answers
anyway, so just write what is true
for you.
Below that on each section. You're going to see kind of a scoring
scale again. Generally this
doesn't change a lot but it does based on
the number of questions in each section. So make
sure you're paying attention and checking the right
score. Otherwise, that will mess up
your wheels as well.
And then you're going to transfer them to your scoring sheet, which
is the wheels page once again, and to do
that. I'm just know that the center of each wheel where there's
a black circle is zero. It's like
the hubcap of the wheel is zero and then each pig out from
that. You count one two, three four, you should
never have an answer on the Outer Circle. We
do that on purpose because that means you're
perfect and nobody gets there until you're in heaven. So
we always leave room for growth. Even if
you end up scoring high in every area.
So you're gonna transfer so say you
got two answers of the physical wheel questions that
said those are true for me then according
to the scoring skill there. You're going
to score it to and you're gonna put that on the second line
above the hubcap on the nutrition wheel,
so you'll score
each one of them that way when you complete a will you're gonna connect your
dots and that's how you will.
Kind of see what your will in that area of your life. Looks like
And then there's one more part under the scoring
mechanism on each section on this
nutrition one. It says I struggle with eating disorders and
then there's more under that.
When we redid this intake several years ago, we wanted
to capture some information but we didn't want
to say oh you have an eating disorder minus one
and duck them for something when maybe that's the
reason they're coming in for help and why they have some physical
issues. So we decided to put those questions separately.
We take the information, but we
don't Factor it into the score. So that's why those
are separate. So each area of questions is
modeled like this. So we're gonna
go ahead and pause the video and go ahead
and do your intake transfer all of your scores to
the wills and draw your Wills then turn the
video back on and we'll wrap this up. Welcome back before we
tie everything together. I want to point out
a few nuances on the intake that maybe you
didn't catch maybe you did but for our patience, these
are ways for us to educate them on the
whole person healing and the other resources that we
have available to them here at MOJ.
So on the physical wheel the nutrition's questions,
there was one that says I am interested in
meeting with a nutritionist we have that available. We put
that in the intake so that they know and that we are
reminded to talk to them about that opportunity if they want
it when you got to the substances questions,
there is one that says I
want to know more about a program that helps people with
Hurts Habits and Hang-Ups. That's when we can tell them
about Celebrate Recovery that meets every Monday night and refer them
to to that for help. There are multiple places
in the intake that we can
point them to social services at ministries of
Jesus, whether it's I don't have means to buy healthy food and
I can't afford to or their struggling with financial
burdens. Those all are reminders
to say. Hey, make sure you talk to Social
Services before you leave on the
relational wheel we offer divorce care
for anyone needing that assistance.
On the emotional wheel we offer grief share
if anybody has suffered a loss that they're struggling to
cope with and we also point to them
that we have free counseling available
for our medical patients. If that
would be helpful for them. Again. They can't afford the medical care.
Therefore. They're not going to be able to afford the counseling and if we
believe in whole person healing then we want to make sure that we
offer that to them for free as well. So those are
some just nuances that I wanted you to be
aware of that helps our patients understand everything that
we have to offer here.
On the spiritual will we do provide Bibles in
their languages? Because we think that's
super important for them to have if we don't have
their language we will order it for them. It's just
so important that we do that sharing the
gospel can come up at any time during the intake and
that can mean a lot of things if it's a returning patient
and we know that they're a Believer. We just
want to pour more scripture into them to encourage them. But if
they're a new patient or we don't know if they have that
relationship with Jesus, we want to make sure we take the
opportunity. So you'll see on the back of your scripture Pages how
to have a relationship with God and
we will literally walk through that page step by
step with them to help them know how they can have
that relationship with Jesus.
You'll see also on the top of the spiritual will we ask
what religion they are? And that's because we serve every
religion that comes through the door at ministries of
Jesus. I've done intakes with the Muslim
before and so if they're devout then they pray
five times a day and their prayer area will come
out looking very strong. But when we see that
there are Muslim then we read that through a different lens. So
we will never Force Christ on
anybody that doesn't want to listen but we always want to ask. Hey, can
I share this with you? So even if
it doesn't happen during the intake, they're gonna
be asked by their nurses and their Physicians. Hey, can
I pray for you and scripture is going to be shared in those appointments as
well. So the gospel is through and through at MOJ,
but the intake is the first chance
we get to share that with our patients. So
back to your wheels that you have drawn ask
yourself if these were the wheels
on my car.
How well would that car be getting down the road?
We asked that question at our intakes every time
and a lot of times. This is where the patient will look at
us and just kind of chuckle or hang their head and shake it
or they'll say I'd be sitting on the side of the road and
and that's true. And again this goes back
to that three-part being diagram the way that
God created us was intricately woven Body Soul
and Spirit and you cannot separate one part from
the other. So if you're physical will comes out
a little flat even if
the other three wheels are good, if that's your car
that one low tire is gonna wear and tear
on the other good ones over time. You've got to keep
them all properly inflated to get down the road with your
car and the same is true for life if the body stolen Spirit
if one part of that is not well, it's gonna
affect how you get down the road of life.
So at MOJ again, it comes back to
we want to help heal the whole person Body Soul
and Spirit. So just
Remember that look at your Wills. How are you doing and
see what areas of your
life you might need to improve on? So on the goals page
that last page of the packet is optional and
we encourage our patients to
set these goals, but they don't have to if they don't want to
but we try to make them attainable goals.
So if they need for instance better exercise,
they don't get any exercise. Then we
help them think through, you know, do I live in a safe neighborhood
I could go walking in or do I
do I like mornings or evenings? What's better for my schedule? Is
there somebody that I can walk with and even
if they have a goal in the spiritual area of
listening to more scripture than we encourage them
while they're walking You Know download the app listen to it
while you walk and so we really try to help
them with attainable goals. So that
is it for the intake. I hope you learned a
lot about yourself. I know I've done the intake on my own before.
And I thought I was a little healthier than I then my
wheels showed me to be so I hope you learned some things
if there's areas that you need to adjust I encourage you
to do that, but we're done. So I'm
gonna toss the video back to Lacey now and she's gonna wrap us
up.
As you can see from the first and take appointment patients are
exposed to the gospel and the love of Jesus. This is
why we ask for your testimony in the application process. If
you don't have a personal relationship with Jesus, then it
would be hard to share him with others. We want the message our patients to
receive to be consistent with the gospel in order for us
to reach our mission. We are excited that you're serving with
us and MJ pray for the ministry as you serve and we
look forward to seeing what God's gonna do with you don't hesitate. If
you have any questions. I look forward to seeing you next time
you're in be sure to bring your intake your survey and
your release form. Don't worry. We don't grade the intake. We
have a gift for you and we'll be seeing you soon.